a major discovery overnight and the
mysterious disappearance of four young
men that we've been covering all week in
Pennsylvania investigators uncovered a
mass grave that contains multiple human
remains the more than 12 foot deep hole
is on a 90 acre farm the county
prosecutor identified one of the bodies
as 19 year old Dean Finocchiaro he
vanished Friday three other young men
who disappeared around the same time are
still missing the son of the properties
owners Cosmo DiNardo has been arrested
he's charged with stealing a car
belonging to one of the missing men
DeMarco Morgan is in New Hope
Pennsylvania at the farm where the
bodies were discovered DeMarco good
morning to you good morning there are
remains still and at mass graves so
police will be back out here at this
property for a fourth straight day
babbling and Friends of the missing have
been hoping for the best it now appears
they must brace for the words this is a
homicide make no mistake about it buts
County District Attorney met Weintraub
said human remains were found in a mass
grave twelve and a half feet deep I'm
very very sad to say that we can now
identify Dean Finocchiaro
19 years old of Middletown as one of the
people that was found buried in that
grave it was not the outcome meeting at
the midnight news conference wanted to
hear these three Loyola University
students knew Jimmy Patrick's the first
of the four young men to disappear he
was last seen last Wednesday
I think that's what we were looking for
today I only came here before the news
conference the mother mark sturgis who
was still unaccounted for
wrote on facebook this was the act of
pure evil all we can do is continue to
pray for our loved ones and hope that
these boys are found cosmo DiNardo whose
parents owned the farm where the bodies
were buried was arrested wednesday
afternoon on separate charges according
to court filings on Saturday the day
Thomas meal was reported missing DiNardo
offered to sell meals 1996 Nissan Maxima
for five hundred dollars district
attorney Weintraub didn't say - OG ro
was killed or provide a motive it's
unclear how many bodies were in the
grave which was uncovered with the help
of cadaver dogs
we're gonna bring each and every one of
these lost boys home to their families
one way or another we will not rest
until we do that
prosecutors say Gennaro has been
diagnosed with the schizophrenia he is
currently being held on a 5 million
dollars cash bail and the attorney for
his family released a statement - a
scene and I quote as parents mr. and
mrs. DiNardo sympathize with the parents
and families of the missing young men
and they are cooperating in every way
possible with the investigation Nora a
really disturbing story DeMarco thank
you